election day in the Democratic Republic
of Congo was marked by delays in
deploying voting materials and Technical
glitches many people were frustrated
they had turned up early to cast their
ballots at this polling station at the
heart of Kinshasa voting only got
underway hours after polls
opened this is not right we are tired we
left our jobs we not even voted yet when
will we go home it is not a good
sign people are here since 6:00 a.m. to
vote but no one is able to vote but we
will not get
tired at a polling station in the
Southeast katanga Province angry voters
took off with election materials after
they found their names missing from the
register in the central casai region
electoral officials used used whatever
they could to deliver the
materials some parts of the country do
not have a proper Road Network and
supplies had to be transported by air
security challenges in the Northeast are
a big concern because of armed groups
operating there the fighters have made
it hard for displaced congales to
vote this was the scene in IU's
provincial capital Buona confrontation
between police and displaced people from
a nearby C they damaged voting supplies
angry that they were not able to cast
their ballots some Christian election
Observer missions say 31% of polling
station did not open half of the
machines had problems and violence was
reported in several areas Katherine soy
Al jazer
Kinshasa make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer